[Musica]
mi trovo a una festa di compleanno in
sicilia è tardi c'è caldo
decido di ripararmi in un angolo della
villa per riposarmi
a un certo punto si siede accanto a me
una ragazza che conosceva naturalmente
iniziamo a scambiare qualche parola e
insomma sapete come vanno queste cose a
un certo punto si ferma mi guarda e
parafrasando il grande italo calvino
dice
sei il mare
perché entra in un bicchiere
credetemi in quel momento sono diventato
uno scrittore in quel momento sentito
quel fuoco quella scintilla che già era
accesa dentro di me crescere crescere
fino a diventare l'incendio che divampa
ancora oggi ma soprattutto quella
domanda così bella e così semplice mi ha
messo in crisi
tu sei il mare perché vuoi entrare in un
bicchiere
tu che avresti risposto
mette in crisi
ma la crisi può essere l'occasione per
una svolta l'occasione per rivedere le
nostre priorità l'occasione per fare la
rivoluzione nel nostro mondo
e oggi il nostro mondo più che mai è una
piccola stanza con tanta gente che dorme
attorno e c'è un incendio dentro e fuori
di loro oggi più che mai abbiamo il
dovere di rivedere il concetto di
essenziale cosa è
essenziale
sicuramente ciò che è necessario alla
sopravvivenza e potremmo aggiungere ciò
che è necessario a vivere secondo la
nostra idea di felicità
qual è il contrario di essenziale il
superfluo il lusso per esempio
ma tutto il lusso è superfluo
nel rinascimento i grandi signori del
tempo si scoprivano mecenati e
commissionavano e artisti illuminati
meravigliose opere d'arte straordinarie
dimore dipinti sculture
cattedrali cattedrali
opere d'arte che oggi sono visitate da
milioni di turisti da tutto il mondo
sono lussi nascono come lussi né più né
meno
secondo questo ragionamento dunque
l'arte non rientrerebbe nel concetto di
essenziale ma in quello di superfluo
questo è il primo malinteso di cui
voglio parlare oggi un malinteso che è
ovvio che ve lo dico a fare danneggia
innanzitutto gli artisti in quanto
professionisti ma soprattutto danneggia
le comunità che dovrebbero fruire
totalmente pienamente dell'opera d'arte
e non lo possono fare se la intendono
come superfluo è ovvio no e questo
malinteso sommato a un secondo un
secondo terribile malinteso produce un
circolo vizioso che definisco
cancerogeno
quale questo secondo malinteso
siamo a roma in campo marzio e il 28
maggio 1606 tu che facevi il 28 maggio
neanche nei pensieri della mamma e 28
maggio 1606 in campo marzio scoppia una
rissa violentissima tra due individui a
un certo punto uno ha la meglio
sull'altro e lo uccide
subito dopo fugge viene prontamente
incolpato ufficialmente dell'omicidio è
condannato a morte per decapitazione
quell'uomo si chiama michelangelo merisi
noto a tutti allora adesso è per sempre
col nome di caravaggio
e la storia di un assassino
ma è anche la storia di uno dei più
grandi artisti di tutti i tempi e
nessuno sarebbe mettere in discussione
la grandezza della sua opera
eppure oggi accade esattamente il
contrario quando ci troviamo di fronte
un artista che è anche un essere umano
diciamo così discutibile
decidiamo subito di punirlo censurando
distruggendo accanendosi sulle sue opere
perché per chi intendiamo le sue opere
come massima espressione della sua
vanità del suo ego della sua identità
della sua persona addirittura
non può esserci errore più grande
l'opera d'arte non appartiene
esclusivamente all'artista
appartiene alla comunità che può fruirne
appartiene a noi appartiene a me a me
e non può esserci rivalsa risarcimento
vendetta vendetta migliore che
portargliela via farla nostra farne
tesoro e dare un senso allo stare al
mondo di questo individuo e per il resto
è stato discutibile
l'opera d'arte ci appartiene anche se
non l'abbiamo prodotta a noi
e questo è un miracolo
un miracolo che ci riguarda del tutto un
miracolo non è essenziale e molto di più
è molto di meno
un miracolo non esiste e non può
esistere finché non accade finché non è
c'è un terzo malinteso che si aggiunge
questi che riguarda il concetto di arte
come intrattenimento
molto dell'arte nasce per intrattenere
pensiamo al cinema teatro alla musica
insomma
però l'intrattenimento diventato un po
una parolaccia soprattutto nel lessico
nostro in italia cioè inteso in
contrapposizione alle cosiddette cose
serie no quelle produttive in ambito
ovviamente strettamente economico anche
in ambito di formazione purtroppo
insomma dire che l'arte e
intrattenimento significa dire che
l'arte è non è una cosa seria che
riguarda lo svago la gestione del tempo
libero
gli hobby d'arte in ob
ma il nostro immaginario
non è una piccola stanza è una
cattedrale
alta che regge il cielo per intero
e lo fa davvero se glielo nasci fare
questi tre malintesi sono emersi in
tutto il loro orrore
durante la crisi in poi imposta dalla
pandemia è ancora in atto
siamo tutti chiusi in casa
all'improvviso
siamo preoccupati siamo inquieti
le persone cominciano a perdere il
lavoro
le persone cominciano a perdere la vita
vogliono davvero
diventa fondamentale sopravvivere
diventa fondamentale individuare quei
servizi essenziali
a cui non possiamo non dobbiamo
rinunciare ovviamente i servizi sanitari
servizi bancari la produzione la
distribuzione alimentare i trasporti
sono senz'altro essenziali ma l'arte in
particolare le arti dello spettacolo
buona parte delle arti dello spettacolo
vengono congelate messe da parte
stiamo ancora cercando di far entrare il
mare nel bicchiere
ma la realtà la vita intesa come
conservazione come ricerca della
sopravvivenza è un inganno
la realtà è sopravvalutata noi abbiamo
il dovere di cercare la verità
attraverso il torpore talvolta l'orrore
del mondo in cui viviamo
solo così potremo incontrare davvero la
bellezza di cui si parla tanto anche
troppo
la realtà è sopravvalutata e noi
cerchiamo continuamente mondi altri
attraverso le arti attraverso il cinema
la musica la letteratura perché il
nostro non ci piace non ci basta non ci
basta mai
ogni opera d'arte nasce come atto
d'amore e la natura di questo amore è un
mistero
noi abbiamo il dovere di indagarlo ma
non per svelarlo ma al contrario
attenzione per approfondirlo per
renderlo più complesso persino questo
mistero
vi dico un'altra banalità
moriremo tutti
l'importante è che non diventi
un'abitudine
l'arte e la nostra occasione per vivere
per sempre
non lasciamoci morire invano
ti prego non lasciare che io muoia
invano
allora abbiamo chiarito che la vita come
sola sopravvivenza è quantomeno scadente
dell'utente
vi è mai capitato di innamorarvi
perdutamente
ammessi
innamorarsi un po come scoprire una
parola nuova e aver voglia di usarla di
continuo a cercarla nei discorsi degli
altri cercarla per iscritto cercare
continuamente occasioni pretesti per
pronunciarla questa parola nuova
oggi abbiamo bisogno di una parola nuova
sé notevole può essere questa parola
nuova
veneto qualcuno
può essere noi
può essere voi
può essere loro che non ci piacciono mai
o può essere io
io
chi posso essere io
cosa posso fare io adesso
io ho scelto di essere scrittore perché
la parola e armonia e quando le parole
diventano storie storie da raccontare
diventano bellezza bellezza di cui ci
nutriamo e lo facciamo davvero lo
facciamo in tanti modi
avete mai pensato a quanti soldi girano
intorno al mondo dell'arte soprattutto
in questo paese intorno al mondo e lo
spettacolo in particolare
immaginate un artista solo
un'artista solo che riempie uno stadio
migliaia di persone venute a vedere una
persona sola
persone che riempiono bar alberghi
ristoranti
e adesso immaginate quello stesso stadio
all'improvviso vuoto
e con lui bar alberghi e ristoranti
lo sentite questo silenzio
lo percepite questo vuoto
immaginate il danno per un paese danno
economico per un paese come il nostro
che è noto in tutto il mondo come
produttore eccellente da sempre di bello
e buono
e necessario che i professionisti dello
spettacolo ma non solo loro tutti gli
artisti partecipino attivamente ai
processi decisionali di questo paese
attraverso dei programmi strutturati e
che soprattutto partecipino
costantemente e direttamente ai processi
di formazione dei cittadini di oggi e di
domani ed e necessario adesso ci sono
sempre
mille ragioni per non fare qualunque
cosa
noi dobbiamo cercare anche quella sola
occasione che ci sproni a fare che ci
spinge ad agire
se io avessi cercato fuori da me la
buona ragione per fare per scrivere
per fare qualunque cosa non avrei fatto
niente
e invece ho fatto della parola la mia
vita invece sono diventato scrittore
e alla fine ho imparato che il mare può
entrare in un bicchiere
siamo ancora in una piccola stanza
con tante persone che dormono attorno
svegliamo lì tutti
[Applauso]